[Music]
the world is a mysterious place there
are marvels but needs are just waiting
to be discovered by those who are daring
enough to look
Marvel's like the creature I had only
heard existed in legend a mythical
monster straight out of your worst
nightmares with wild eyes and a hideous
face and feet that were amazingly
freakishly
it's a terrifying creature with perfect
white teeth and breath that just smells
all minty fresh and only hair if it has
on its entire body is on the top oh
you're scared of hey don't be scared
it's look it's just a story everyone
knows that the small foot isn't real or
anything oh that's nice real nice way to
scarm for life
[Music]
[Music]
illumination
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
and banana with
black
[Music]
today we will do mean things and we will
do them in style
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
the bridge
[Music]
[Music]
I thought we were you heard your mother
trampolining
superheroes are illegal defines Who I am
we're not saying you have what someone
on TV said I was approached by this
tycoon most to talk about hero stuff
help me bring supers back into the
sunlight
we need Elastigirl
[Music]
kids no problem not the way you're
supposed to do it dad they want to do it
I don't know that way why would they
change math over Dusseldorf do those are
dodging Kyle it's so heavy
atropine closing I couldn't have done
this if you hadn't taken over so well
I've got to succeed so she can succeed
can she get it Bob is tricky but I can't
keep giving it done properly parenting
is a heroic act done properly
[Music]
all right let's get you plugged in with
E or is it wifey why don't we just go in
and we are online
cool
we are going to the super-excited
is one minor thing what is the Internet
holy cow
the girl is tough indeed 10 child stars
went to prison number six will amaze you
redirected to eBay ladies and gentlemen
the next item up a black velvet painting
of a sorrowful kitten it's like it's
looking into my soul yeah that one's
really gonna haunt me for a while
[Music]
thank you no see good see I don't
understand why people like this game
brings in milkshake let's speed it up
pick it pinkie pinkie pinkie
the kitty for a little while
no the kitty gets the milkshake the
bunny cake
[Music]
hubba-hubba Romeo and Juliet are moving
to a whole new garden all clear not
quite perfect but it's ours
think of all the adventures were gonna
have
oh man Kady that is just are you done
humans coming purges everyone they were
supposed to live happily ever after
but when their world is in danger Julia
the gnomes the Roku there's only one
known to call and Sherlock knows sworn
protector of garden gnomes you mean
except for the one you literally just
broke danger of the director of Kung Fu
Panda
we can't anyone hear this but we are
going to smash us all tomorrow night or
an adventure we have to get across that
River
we'll need a ship no [ __ ] Sherlock
you've got a great unknown our next clue
is in the park directions cricket this
follow the blue line on the ground until
you find the giant red Suns MacAvoy and
we block to Attila jaipur mary j blige
and Johnny Depp with original music by
Elton John and Bernie Taupin
they have to go into cover let's go to
forward hold it home to give me I've
never been the back end of a swirl
before
a lot knows that's not how a squirrel
six it's behind mankini can you
demonstrate you cease unduly you see yes
you're acting like a rear end
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
very pants it is wonderful to see you
yesterday's isn't it
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
wait so how many of us early
for over a century the hotel has been
his life next summer
[Music]
[Music]
oh you can eat buffet boat service table
yeah so impressive it's like a hotel on
the water
[Music]
the japanese archipelago'
20 years in the future canine saturation
has reached epidemic proportions an
outbreak of dog flu ripped through the
city of Mecca sake
mayor Kobayashi issues emergency orders
calling for a hasty quarantine trash
island becomes an exiled colony the Isle
of Dogs I don't think I can stomach any
more of this garbage nobody's giving up
around here and don't you forget it
ever your Rex your king your Duke your
boss I'm chief we're a pack of scary
indestructible alpha dogs Atari
Kobayashi you heroically hijacked a
junior turboprop XJ 750 and flew it to
the islands because of your dog
darn it I've got a crush on you we get
the idea you were looking for your lost
dog spots
does anybody know sparks if he's alive
may very well be living even at this
moment as a captive prisoner somebody is
up to something will you help him
the little pilot why should I because
he's a 12 year old boy dogs love those
we'll find him wherever he is if he's
alive we'll find your dog it's gonna be
a fight
[Music]
where somebody spoke his language
Wow to the north a long rickety causeway
over noxious sludge marsh leading to a
radioactive landfill polluted by toxic
chemical garbage that's our destination
right get ready to jump
it's Christmassy time mystery
[Music]
expectations who knows what might happen
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
time has come
[Music]
you